non
[Musique]
dans la cour du village des antiquaires
à versailles une petite boutique et sur
un tout autre rythme que ses voisines
le village avait disparu même même au
plus bas dans les années 90 2000 ya
toujours des gens qui achetaient des
villes s'étaient pressées en plus
petites quantités
c'était aussi beaucoup pour les guider
les producteurs on va dire le marché
s'est jamais arrêté mais c'est vrai
qu'il adore repris depuis quelques
années il est toujours avons maintenant
le grand public le syndicat national de
l'édition phonographique a comptabilisé
une progression des ventes de vinyles
sur l'année 2010 est de 72%
une tendance bien confirmé pour tous les
publics
on peut penser des fois que ça marche et
un peu pointu eux pour des choses voilà
c'est pointu eu assez underground on
pourrait dire quoi et en fait moi on en
est tous même les nouveaux trucs de
johnny
sortir ue est vraiment tout ce qui sort
ressort également en ville ici on trouve
des nouveautés mais on est bien surtout
pour dénicher des pépites d'occasions
parfois rares sans guitare voilà c'est
un disque original pressage us et donc
c'est la seule édition qui existent je
n'ai pas réédité il ya peu de chances
qu'il soit réédité deux profs donc le
seul moyen de m'avoir voilà c'est
d'aller dans les dents les petits
disquaires des simples curieux aux
collectionneurs de tous les âges nicolas
n'a pas de client type même si des
tendances de vente se dégage
je pense que c'est ce qui se vend le
plus en vue mais c'est tout ce qui est
propre
après le jazz soul funk que si ça marche
d'un hip hop techno aussi beaucoup de
beaucoup de dj d'acheter des maxi de
house n'est que le fait beaucoup de
disco ce week-end le disquaire de la
place des antiquaires participera à sa
toute première convention de vigny avec
plus de 3 millions d'adeptes en france
en 2010 est le disque à sion n'est pas
près de disparaître